i'm going to introduce you now
um uh hi everyone welcome to the
rmk distinguished lecture series this is
lecture series we established uh to
celebrate uh the role of
the carp who was the simonistic finding
director
and not only the role in simon's
institute but most importantly the role
in theoretical computer science you know
formulating the central problems
contributing stunning results
and in that spirit we feature visionary
leaders in the field of threat of
computer science
and we're especially grateful today to
uh have
tony pitasi for our speaker and
tony is a professor university of
toronto i think
she's a hold of a bell research chair
for now
and she's a member of the vector
institute where she also holds a sifar
ai chair
and she's also a visitor in ies has been
visited for the last four or five years
and her research is all she's done so
fundamental research in many areas
uh probably most well-known complexity
theories
specializing in proof complexity
communication complexity but she's also
done a lot of work on privacy
differential privacy and algorithmic
fairness
and she's had breakthrough papers in all
of these fields
you know showing from lower bounds
mostly in the proof complexity area
to in what i would call an upper bound
that is defining models where you
can achieve fairness protocols for
fairness and for differential privacy
and tony's also a legendary mentor to
post
to post docs to students and personal
friend
and most important her talk today is
entitled uh
how difficult it is to certify that a
random stat formula is
unsatisfiable so please uh join me in
welcoming tony
welcome well thank you thank you sophie
um it's great
thank you uh oh can you hear me yes
okay it's great to be here um uh
particularly honored to be invited to
the
richard carp distinguished seminar
series i was thinking about what i could
talk about and i actually do have one
paper with dick carp although
we didn't know each other i didn't know
i mean i knew of him but i
never met him i think when we had the
paper and i think it was
it was a joint paper with paul beam and
mike sacks
and myself and decarbon i think it was
either mike or paul that were
uh talking to dick so anyways i was
lucky to uh
to have an early paper with him and so i
picked this topic albert
serious suggested it maybe not realizing
that but i picked this topic because
it's something i thought about way back
even in
grad school when i was supervised by
steve cook and so for the special year
on
um satisfiability and np completeness
plus the carp lecture i thought this
would be a good topic it's an old topic
and it's basically trying to understand
how hard it is to
prove that a random formula in the
unsatisfiability regime how hard it is
to prove that
and i certainly don't own this topic but
i'm going to give you my perspective on
it
and yes i can see some of you and if
anybody
has any questions you're free to
interrupt me i probably won't notice if
you raise your hand though so just
um i don't know interrupt her
they say that we cannot they cannot see
you but is there any need to see
you know you can't see me
i think you so i can see myself i have
two screens on
uh one of them is is uh you can see me
on one of them i think
okay okay good good let's keep going
okay great okay
perfect um so just to start with basics
ksat
is a um a cnf formula so it's a it's a
conjunction of clauses
and each clause consists of a
disjunction of literals
of course the famous np complete problem
and given such a formula
over say n variables you want to output
yes if it's satisfiable
in other words if there's a boolean 0 1
assignment to the variables that
that satisfies or that evaluates the
formula to 1
or to true and you want to say onset or
zero otherwise if every assignment
falsifies the formula
and the question i want to talk about
here is so we're in that regime where
the f
is unset and we want to know how hard it
is to to prove or certify that such a
form is
unsucked so to talk about this we're
going to take a little little brief
uh digression uh on into proof
complexity so what is a proof
so informally uh proof is just when you
think of a proof
as like a graph where the input nodes
that's in purple
i don't know if you consider that purple
or pink but anyways
uh the input vertices uh which are in
this picture at the top
they're labeled with axioms or initial
assertions such as the clauses so we're
going to assume that
all the clauses are true there's an
assignment that evaluates the true we're
assuming that for a second contradiction
and then you have some sequence of you
have some set of rules that you can use
to derive new
formulas from previous formulas and the
goal is to finally
derive the the identically false or the
empty formula
that's what a proof would look like if
you're trying to refute an
unsatisfiability an unsatisfiable
formula
and if you're trying to prove a
tautology then the uh the purple
uh nodes will be labeled with formulas
that are axioms uh they're always true
uh and simple axioms and then the bottom
would be labeled with the tautology that
you're trying to refute
so um hey sorry yeah yeah
but they there's a technical issue here
that the panelists
are claiming um
they cannot see your video which is not
good
so you need to switch
i'm going to turn this whole thing off
and then tony i think if you just
if you just unmute your other camera
okay
source and then i mean use the audio
from that one and then
uh mute the one you're currently
currently using
the microphone you're currently using
okay hopefully that'll help
so i don't i don't have that it's muted
it's
it's it's not muted i i don't think that
you're connected to audio on the other
camera
oh okay now they say they can see you
okay i did nothing
so i'm not sure i don't know fine
okay if we chose the speaker view we
could see only the t
but if we choose the other image we can
see the video this was it
oh all right so i was is everybody good
no problem
okay
can you still can everybody still see
everything
okay i'll keep i'll keep going unless i
hear but yeah complain
okay so here's an example a resolution
is one of the simplest um
proof procedures and there's only one
rule the resolution rule
which is you can take two clauses it it
operates on lines that are
just clauses so at the top here are all
the clauses of the formula f
that we're trying to refute and the rule
lets you take two clauses where
one contains a variable and then the
other one contains the negation of that
variable
so like here a or b and not b or c
b is the common variable that occurs in
one positively and the other one
negatively
and the rule allows you to derive the
disjunction of all the remaining
literals removing the b
from it okay and that's a sound and
complete rule so if
f is on set then there is always a
sequence of applications of this one
resolution rule that allows you to
derive the empty clause
so this is a picture of a of a dag
associated with a resolution refutation
of this formula
okay um so that's intuitively what we
think of as a proof but it was
formally defined um more abstractly
by copenh in 1975 and their definition
of an abstract or general proof system
is a polytime function
that takes strings onto the set of unset
cnf formulas
and the way you should think of this
function as the
so for a proof system p you think of the
associated function
a is taking as input a string w where
you think of w
as an encoding of a of a p proof of some
formula and then a of w just verifies
that it is a proof and returns the
formula that is proving
okay and you want that procedure
a to be polynomial time so you want to
be able to verify that something's a
proof in polynomial time
okay and what it's a proof of and
since this definition is so general is
more or less
the same as defining uh a proof system
to be an
np well a feasible proof system to be an
np procedure
for solving solving onset so the theorem
is that
there exists an abstract proof system
where all unset
c and f's have poly size proof if and
only if n p equals column t
so does that make sense um
so this led to what's referred to as ms
cook's program
although i'm not sure this is what he
had in mind at the time but when the
program is to
basically build up techniques for
proving lower bounds for stronger and
stronger
standard proof systems and eventually if
we can prove lower bounds
on every proof system in other words
show for every abstract proof system
there's some sequence of unset formulas
that require super polynomial length
proofs
then that implies n p naught equal
column p
and also at p not and therefore p naught
equal np as well
um so this is was was defined in the
early 70s and since then
and even in their seminal original paper
they defined a whole bunch of
types of proof systems the most standard
being the phraga system where the lines
are
formulas and you have some fixed set of
rules that allow you to derive
new formulas from previous ones in some
sound way
and this is sort of like a picture you
see a lot of different proof systems
and the the hierarchy of them so as you
go up they get stronger in the sense
that
uh if you have like tc zero fraga with
the arrow two ac zero fraga
that means it can p simulate the one
below it in other words
any formula that has a small ac 0
refutation would also have a small
tc0 trigger refutation so as you go up
the proof system has
more more expressive power the rules are
stronger and so you can drive
prove more things with shorter proofs
um and so we're kind of like this
boundary here of the green
shows currently where we can prove super
polynomial or exponential lower bounds
and above the
green line we're really really stuck at
the moment
um so there's a second motivation
for studying proof complexity and lower
bounds in particular
which is even if you don't think this
program is ever going to lead to showing
that np doesn't equal common p
it turns out that these proof systems
are very natural
and even understanding a fixed proof
system that's a general natural one like
resolution or like fraga
that tells you a whole lot about a large
family of underlying algorithms for
solving sat
in particular if you take a run of some
any complete algorithm for solving sat
sorry if you take a run of any complete
algorithm for solving
sat satin run it on an unstacked formula
the transcript of the run
of the algorithm you can view that as a
proof of the unsatisfiability of the
formula
and it turns out that even if you run a
set a complete set algorithm on
satisfiable formulas depending on the
proof system sometimes that can yield
insight
into and to uh sometimes in the process
of doing that running a satellite on a
sat instance you sometimes end up having
to prove
sub formulas or related formulas are
unset
in the process so the bottom line is
approving lower bounds on particular
proof systems
has a lot of applications to our
understanding of large classes of
related algorithms
and here's just some examples this has
been talked a lot about in the special
semester
uh people in the audience are definitely
more experts than i am on this but
resolution lower bounds
for example proves that any resolution
based sat algorithm requires exponential
time in the worst case and so cdcl
is you know very um
extremely important uh kind of family of
algorithms that are used to solve sat
and run quite quickly in practice
cutting planes is another example that's
a proof system
and so lower balance for cutting planes
proofs rules out
a different family of algorithms that
are based on this branch and cut
procedure from optimization
and there's been a proliferation of
results about the proof system sum of
squares
where they're very tightly connected to
a large family of semi-definite programs
for
solving exactly and approximating lots
of np hard problems
also related to extension complexity
which is another model of computation
that's been used and studied extensively
to solve np heart problems
so the bottom line is that understanding
the complex proof complexity
of formulas in this system helps us to
understand
not unconditional lower bounds but at
least lower bounds for a
important large family of algorithms
everybody can hear me because i see
seeing some new things on the
is there still a problem with the
was hearing me everybody can hear you
there's another
thing about seeing you but uh i think
this is fine okay
tony i'm starting to interrupt it's just
that your your camera's off on the
device you're using to speak into so
if you want to keep it that way it's
fine it's just uh we won't see you on
the
video that's all okay um let's see if i
can fix that
yeah i'm sorry i don't know why it's off
it shows that it's on so
sorry about that okay
okay so some of the main questions that
we ask in proof complexity i'll just
quickly
as we want to understand for a
particular proof system which formulas
have poly size refutations
and we're even interested in proving
conditional lower bounds under some
uh not under the assumption np not equal
co and p but under
a different conditional result maybe an
assumption about
one-way functions or a crypto assumption
or an assumption about
either hardness of a function on average
or worst case would be great
um we also interested in understanding
the question of how hard it is
is it to find or search for a proof in a
particular proof system that's called
automatizability of the proof system we
also like to
uh relate what i was just saying before
we want to relate proofs in this proof
system to
natural families of algorithms so that
understanding
lower bounds on this proof system gives
us
we can leverage that to prove lower
bounds on limitations of exact and
approximation
algorithms that are based on p the proof
system p
and then we want to be able to compare
the strength of the proof system p to
other systems
okay so one thing that that is a big
problem for
us once you get to a reasonably strong
proof system like
a phraga system the phraga system is
just a very general
system where the lines think about that
dag that i drew the lines
or the circles are labeled with formulas
so as a polysized proof those lines
would be labeled with polynomial sized
formulas
and the number of formulas should be
polynomial size and the rules are just
sort of there's a whole there's many
different ways you can aximetize a
phragus system but you can just pick
some fixed set of
finite fixed set of rules schemas that
allows you to derive
you know any you know that sounded
complete
and one issue that we have big issue
that we have is it's actually really
hard to come up with
formulas that are hard in the sense that
we think that you know it's an infinite
family of formulas and
that's that was that's unsatisfiable but
yet
uh it's hard to prove them and say a
fragrance system or
found a depth figure system um
yeah so what what sasha said in uh his
survey article is awfully difficult to
come up with even candidate
hardhatologies there's no such thing as
tons of anti-complete problems at our
disposal
and the way i would say it is we're in
this conundrum where if you
so you have to be able to come up with a
statement that you can express
propositionally so you can't just decide
to write down
um you know some really hard theorem and
math that you think
requires a hard proof you have to be
able to write it down propositionally
and for those types of statements that
can be expressed propositionally
it tends to be the case that number one
either
um so either either they're um
true uh in other words they're
that that was supposed to be uh yeah not
not true so either they're not a
tautology so that's that rules them out
because then no
proof system can prove them or they are
known to be
tautology um or they're not known to be
true or false
so a statement where you know we don't
know if it's for example you could write
down a statement that says that
um sat doesn't have small circuits so
that's an example of a statement that we
think is
false and we think it's true that
doesn't have small circumstances but we
don't know
and so it's hard to even study the
length of a proof of something when you
don't
have any insight into whether it's true
or false or not and then the third
case is where we do have a system of
formulas that we know is true like the
pigeonhole principle or something like
that
but usually if we know it's true there's
a proof of it and if there's a proof of
it
there's a fragrant proof or extended
fighter proof that's why those proof
systems were defined because
they kind of capture almost everything
that we know how to prove that's
propositional
so we're in this bind where like we have
a proof system that's strong enough
pretty much to prove almost everything
that we know to be true
um but we're trying to prove lower
bounds for it so we have to come up with
something that
you know that is still true but that we
can't formalize in this system
so that's sort of the conundrum that
we're in so a natural thing to do is to
look at
random distributions on random formulas
um so random cnfs everybody probably
knows that they are so we're going to
denote script f delta nk to be the
distribution of random formulas
where you pick delta times n clauses
each of
length or each of with k so each has k
literals in them
and it's not hard to show using a union
bound but for
when delta is a sufficiently large
constant if you pick a random formula
from this distribution it'll be unset
with high probability and there's been
a lot of beautiful work on this showing
that this actually does have this
sharp threshold for every k there is a
sharp threshold value
delta sub k i'm calling it delta k
star which for k equals three is roughly
4.267
where if you choose uh less than
that many clauses that special number
delta 3 star
times n many clauses it'll almost
certainly be uns
dissatisfiable but if you choose more
than that many clauses it'll almost
certainly be unset
so there's the sharp threshold happening
at this value
and um so the idea is okay let's just
consider
this distribution where delta is
sufficiently large so to the right of
the red line
so in that regime we know that the form
is almost certainly satisfiable and we
have
an abundance of them so that's good and
so now the goal would be to try to show
or understand how hard these are to
refute
okay uh and so early on back when i was
in grad school
um uh bart selman and uh
hector levesque and some other people
were uh were
really interested in this and they sort
of i think it's their work that
spearheaded the the thinking about these
random forms and how hard they are to
refute
and so they did some kind of empirical
experiments and showed
that even though for k equals three in
this picture even though the threshold
is at
you know 4.267 that even if you pick
many many many more clauses
you know i don't know a thousand n many
clauses you're way above the threshold
and if you look at standard resolution
based sat
algorithms for solving these instances
way above the threshold
the run time looked like it was uh yeah
the run time looked like it stayed
really high for a long time
um and so it seems like from from the
point of view of these resolution based
algorithms that passing this transition
point
is just completely unnoticed by
resolution so resolution somehow thinks
even when we're so far above the
threshold
that's consistent with the resolution
resolution doesn't recognize that
they're unset now
um and there's other families of random
cnf
formulas that you could study that have
been studied that are super interesting
as well
i just want to mention this briefly
because um i think there's just as
interesting
um they don't have quite the same long
history but they're just as interesting
so other random
constraints satisfaction problems like
random xor or random kcsp
uh the the planted clique or the random
cliques
problem has been studied extensively
where you're now you're picking uh
the the distribution is over graph so
you pick a graph g
from the erdos randy distribution where
you
pick each edge with to be in the graph
with probability p
and for p a half there's a threshold
where the clique has size roughly log n
um
and and that's yeah so p equals half is
the threshold for
clicks of size log n um and so people
study you know the formula corresponding
to this graph which is a formula that
says that g has a clip of size say
2 log in and we know because there's a
sharp threshold there that that's
almost certainly on you know for almost
all g it's going to be unsatisfiable
because the biggest click will have size
n and so this
is another example of a random family of
formulas that are unset
and how hard is it to prove them um the
third one is
is interesting also for for
lots of reasons that it gets to kind of
gets to the meta mathematics of the p
versus np question
so now here you take a distribution
where you pick a random
boolean function f so that's a boolean
function on n
variables so to describe f is like two
to the n
bits and that's so you pick f
at random and then hard sub s with a
parameter s
is a is a c and f formula that states
that
um that f is is computed by a size
s circuit and so for s being polynomial
and g and f a random function since
almost all functions
you know are not computed by polysize
circuits for a random function
hard f sub s and s polynomial hard f
will be
unset and again the question is how hard
is to prove this and this is
kind of trying to understand how hard it
is to prove the non-uniform version of p
naught equal np
so i think these random families are
super interesting to study
um and you know one motivation is to
study this
to understand they're interesting in
their own right uh
understanding them relates to structural
properties of
you know np hard optimization problems
and in the case of the last example i
gave it relates to our
understanding of the p versus np
question um from a
slightly more practical point of view it
gives a distribution of instances to use
as benchmarks for sat
algorithms and as i mentioned before
like lower bounds for particular systems
especially for these particular
distributions of formulas
helps us to understand inapproximability
approximation algorithms for a large
related family of algorithms
okay so why is it so hard so now i'm
going to just focus on
uh the the unset random onset formula
where we picked
you know m clauses where m
is more than m is equal to delta n where
delta is bigger than the threshold
and so one question is why is it why
does it seem so hard to certify
that a random formula is unset we know
that by a simple counting argument that
they're almost all on set so why is it
so hard to actually
prove that a particular one is unset and
one kind of obvious thing that is
important
is that in circuit there's a big
difference here between circuit
complexity
and proof complexity so in circuit
complexity it's easy to show
that a random function requires big
circuits because the number of functions
on n variables is like 2 to the 2 to the
n
and the number of poly size circuits is
more like 2
to the poly n so there's way more
functions than there are
small circuits and so that means that
you know almost all functions are hard
and proof complexity
we don't have the same we can't do the
same thing so the number of proofs of
size s
is roughly proportional to the number of
onset formulas so we can't just use a
counting argument
to say well we have all these formulas
that so many formulas are on set
relative to the the number of short
proofs
um and then the second issue is uh
i guess i stole this name truth versus
proof from boaz
um which is that you know the truth is
we don't really know
uh if these formulas we're in this
regime now where we don't know if this
is
if it's true or not so we know that most
of them
are unset that's true but we don't know
if they're hard to refute
and so back in 98 paul and i wrote a
survey and where we said
the only known lower balance for random
formulas are for resolution
in the absence of lower bounds for
random set is quite northward
noteworthy especially given the lack of
good upper bounds in any system even
extended fraga
so the point is is that we think they're
hard but we don't have any evidence
really in either direction except for
resolution bounds that i'll tell you
about
um and the really weird thing is that we
have no
upper bound so you would think well we
do have some but they're pretty trivial
i'll get to them in a minute but you
would think that you know if you're a
little bit above the threshold or maybe
not you know a large enough constant
away from the threshold
that then somehow you could exploit the
fact that they're so unsatisfiable
that you could come up with a way to
refute them but um but that's not the
case
and in fact feigus hypothesis is a
formulation of exactly
this question of exactly this hypothesis
that
uh that it is that there are no short
proofs of any type
for unset formulas so um he defines
what uh what it what is a ref he defines
something called a refutation algorithm
which which is just an algorithm
that takes his input a formula from this
random distribution
above the threshold and since almost all
formulas are unset above the threshold
you can't just
say well the algorithm has to say um
you know it has to get the right answer
almost all the time
because then it could just say that
they're all unset and
they'd be done so instead you want to
say that it has to output yes where
yes means it's unset it has to say that
sufficiently often
say with probability half so it has to
get the right answer on a lot of the
onset formulas
in the distribution and any time it's a
rare one that's satisfiable
it always has to give the right answer
so it always has to say no
and he hypothesized that this is hard
there's no polytone refutation on for f
and also that there's no
proof system that has short refutations
of a random f
and this has been extremely useful as a
hypothesis
it's been shown certain problems that
have been super stubborn
in terms of proving anything about have
been shown to be hard under figa's
conjecture uh certain approximation
problems
that have resisted uh proving that
they're hard under
normal np hardness assumptions and also
other problems uh
more met of the meta mathematical type
like the average case version of
mcsp and famous result about pac
learning dnf
um which were connect we're shown to be
connected to phi geese conjecture in the
if
i guess hypothesis is true then these
problems are also hard
okay so i wanted to say i just wanted to
make sure
i just want to check on one thing so um
is this
i should finish by one or before then
sorry 10 your time
no you can it would be great if you
leave some time for questions so if you
want to
leave five minutes for question but okay
okay and okay but it's so it's twelve to
one right or it's over it
yeah okay okay okay so let me just tell
you a little bit about the upper bounds
for random set uh um so it
there's so this was the paper that with
with carp that i mentioned before
and i believe this upper bound the idea
was actually due to him
so the best we have for k equals three
so when you're looking at random
k-set formulas that you actually once
you get
once you pick uh almost n-squared
clauses
uh then then there are polynomial size
resolution refutations and more
generally
uh to end to the k roughly into the k
minus one clauses is what you need if
you're if you're doing random case set
so that's so far above the threshold
it's it's not even funny
remember there's only like n to the
third many possible clauses causes so
we're
you know extremely unsatisfiable and for
tc0 fragra which is a
very strong subsystem of fraga
of course that means it also holds for
fredo these are upper bounds so fraga
can refute
random three-stat formulas where the
number of clauses is n to the 1.4
so it's better than resolution but it's
again we're still super far away from
from the threshold and this result was
uh proved not constructively by faiga
kim onofa it's a really interesting
paper and then
it was shown by mueller and samarat that
you could formalize their
their upper bound in phrygia systems
uh and for lower bounds so the picture
almost looks the same
as the before i showed you a picture of
lower bounds for proof systems where
we could pick any formula we wanted here
this picture is lower bound specifically
for random set
and the only difference between the
other green line and this one is
a c zero fraga we don't have lower
bounds for a random
sat even though we do have lower bounds
for ac zero figure for other formulas
and cutting planes which is a relatively
new result that i'll mention at the end
of the talk
now we do have lower bounds i the dotted
line runs through it because it's for
uh k has to be at least log n
or to log in so we don't know
the lower bounds if k is a constant for
cutting planes
and again everything in purple is hard
and that's what we're at right now
so here's a more detailed picture of
some of the lower bounds that have been
proven
so i'm going to first tell you a little
bit about the resolution lower bound
it was originally proven so the first
lower bounds for resolution were due to
general resolution bonds were due to
arma haken and that was
followed up by a a really lovely paper
by alistair erkhardt that
used the same technique to prove lower
bounds for for a different distribution
of hard formulas based on mod 2 counting
and then katal and samurai in another
breakthrough paper proved
lower bounds for random sat above the
threshold and so they proved it when m
is some sufficiently large constant
times n
and then in the paper with paul and mike
saxon dick cart and also
proven by benson sununu bigerson we're
able to push this up to
the lower bound still holds even when
the number of clauses is like n to the
1.5 for k equals 3.
um so i'm going to first tell you about
that result and then i'll briefly
talk about the cutting plane's lower
bound as well
any questions so far
okay my only question is you use hard in
different ways so when you think about
all those other things about the
green line being hard you mean it's hard
to prove that they are hard
right right good point um right so what
i mean
here is that above the green line we
have no idea
whether whether say fraga or tc zero
fraga
has short proofs of uh random
random onset formulas uh
so we're we don't i don't care in
general we'd like to be able to prove
lower bounds
for anything uh for these for tc zero
and up we don't have lower bounds for
any
formulas at all and the reason we're
focused on random ones is because
there's not many other choices
and so uh there i'd be happy to prove a
lower bound is for
random formulas where we're just
slightly above the threshold just so as
long as they're unsat
does that make sense and below the line
we
we do have proofs that random formulas
are hard to refute for those proof
systems
does that make it more clear yeah okay
okay so i'm just going to give you a
first i'm just going to
try to explain a nice way to think about
uh
these resolution and the same you can
use the same way
there's going to be this running through
all of these lower bounds is the idea
of thinking of a proof system as being
as
solving a search problem a total search
problem related to
the unset formula and the search problem
is uh
given an assignment to all the variables
that underlie the formula
output some clause that's falsified by
the assignment
so that's sort of we want to kind of um
go from sort of a syntactic proof to
some kind of semantic
thinking about the proof so that we can
use some combinatorial arguments to
prove
to you know to prove a lower bound so
this is going to be the
the function that we're going to be
interested in we're going to kind of
study different proof systems and see
that you can view different proof
systems uh proofs and those proof
systems as sort of models of certain
restricted types for solving the search
problem
so the simplest example is tree
resolution so tree resolution is
a resolution proofs with the property
that
they're tree-like meaning that the
intermediate clauses that you derive in
the proof can only be used once
so if you want to use an intermediate
clause more than once you have to
rederive it
so proofs in general are weaker than
dag-like proofs
and this is an observation that was made
a long time ago i'm not even sure who
gets the credit for it which is that
tree resolution proofs are basically
exactly the same
as decision trees for solving the search
problem
so if you have a tree resolution
refutation of a formula
by looking at it slightly slightly
differently
it is a decision tree for solving the
search problem and vice versa if you
have a decision tree for the search
problem
you can kind of think of it as a tree
resolution proof and here's just a proof
by picture
on the left is a resolution proof i
flipped it now so that the
the clauses are at the bottom and the
empty clause which is what we're
eventually trying to derive is at the
top
um and it you can see it's a it's a tree
uh it's not it's not a tree in the sense
that the leafs
the leaf clauses the the clauses of f
can be used more than once
so i could have just repeated them
instead of making it look like it wasn't
a tree but you it is a tree
and then the the way you think about it
as a decision tree is whatever variable
you resolved on
that's the that's what you label the
vertex with so for example here
the clause x2 negated or x3 or x4
is resolved with x3 negated or x4 so x3
is the variable we're resolving on
so we label the corresponding parent
vertex
with the with the variable or the query
x3
so we ask what's the value of x3 and we
do this for all of the resolution steps
we always just label the parent one with
the variable that's resolved upon
and and then the leaves are still
labeled with uh
with the claws and that so that's a
decision tree
and the leaves the labe the leaves which
are labeled with the
clauses those are the causes that are
violated by that partial assignment to
that
leaf so in the right here for example
when x4 is one
that falsifies the clause x4 negated and
so
that's that's the answer and so on does
that make sense to everybody
mike um tony this is vijay here yes how
are you doing
uh for the assignment zero one one
yes did i make a mistake in my picture
uh
it appears i did make a mistake mistake
in my picture sorry
yeah okay okay yeah i think i just
forgot to
oh no i think it's okay oh it should be
one zero
should be one zero zero i labeled them
wrong yeah sorry okay
yeah yeah sorry about that okay
um so if so because of this connection
it's not hard to prove tree-like
resolution bounds for random formulas
you just have to argue uh
so to argue that the proof has to be
that the tree has to be deep
let's do that first that's just a matter
of uh
arguing and it kind of follows by
expansion if you have a random formula
and somebody asks you the value of a
variable
you want to you want to pick the
direction or pick the setting of that
variable
that's going to leave the formula under
that restriction still
still relatively hard by hard i mean
that you can't like
locally find a contradiction so you have
to sort of look at lots of clauses to
get the contradiction
and i'm not going to do this today but
it's not hard to come up with an
adversary strategy
that's based on the expansion of a
random
formula by expansion of a random formula
i mean if you look at the
clause to variable bipartite graph where
you
have clauses on vertices for the clauses
on the left and vertices for variables
on the right
and you put an edge between a clause and
a variable if that variable occurs in
the clause
that graph is going to be very highly
expanding in general
and because of that that there's going
to be an adversary strategy
that's going to force a path no matter
what the tree looks like it's going to
force a path of linear height
now what about for dag-like resolution
so where it's not necessarily a tree
so we would like to come up with a model
uh
we'd like to have a kind of a top-down
view of dag like resolution proofs the
same way we had a top-down view of
tree-like resolution so you might think
well the first thing
well if tree light corresponds to
decision trees for solving the search
then dag-like should correspond to
branching programs for solving the
search and so i first just want to show
you that that
doesn't work so it turns out that every
onset formula the search problem
associated with it has a
linear size a really small branching
program for solving the search problem
and here's an example uh the form the
formula f here is unset
and what the what the branching program
does is you just query all of the
variables in the first clause so query
x1 and we'll query x2
and there's a unique assignment to those
variables that forces the clause to
false in this case x1 0x2
1 and so for that assignment you you're
done that's the leftmost one on the
picture on the right so you label that
with a clause c1
which is falsified by that assignment
and and now for all the other
assignments for x1 and x2 you know that
they satisfy this clause
so this is where we use the fact that
the branching program is dag-like we can
we can for all of those possibilities we
we can just
merge them all to this to a single
vertex which is the one shown on the
right at the top
and then we can query the variables of
clause 2. and so we keep doing this and
when we finally
get to the second to the last clause
you know we query x2 and x3 and if
they're both
0 then clause 3 is false and now we know
if they're not both 0
and so far now we know that none of c1
c2 c3 has been set to 0
then we know because f is unset that c4
must be
set so we can just label the remaining
paths by c4 even though we haven't
actually gotten a witness to the fact
that c4 is false
so this is bad news from the point of
view of it is a branching program
that solves the search problem but it's
not like a proof or you wouldn't think
of it you you don't really think of it
as a proof because
you don't kind of if you look at it you
don't in the case of c4 being zero you
you don't
you're not convinced that c4 is zero
does that make sense to people
so raspberry off uh
in 95 he uh
not actually sure he my name i'm not
sure who gets the credit for
for this uh but there is a way to think
about resolution as a as a type of a
branching partner but it has some more
conditions on it
so it's a dag so it is it's like like a
branch of quantum it's a dag where the
vertices are all labeled
so each vertex is labeled with you you
want of with a variable that you're
querying just like before
and one side is the variable zero and
the other side it's one
and it you also can remember at any
vertex
a subset of literals which are literals
that are
so you can think of it as remembering a
partial assignment so far
and so it should be a partial assignment
that's consistent with all the paths to
that
vertex so if you know if one path to a
vertex
set x one to zero and another path set x
one to one then you wouldn't remember x
one because
it's not consistent whereas if you had a
vertex where all the paths
to that vertex queried x1 and set it to
one
then you could remember x1 is one if you
wanted to
okay uh and the soundness property that
we need is that
uh when you go down in this tree
uh that you know you're kind of
every assignment follows a unique path
from the root to a leaf
and we want it to be the case that uh
you know
that that the assignments
the assignments that make it to a
particular node all of those assignments
have to either
make it to the left node or to the right
node or not or both
and then at the bottom at the leaf node
we want we
want to label the leaf nodes have to be
labeled with clauses from the search
problem
and those clauses have to include so
whatever is remembered at that
leaf vertex the partial assignment says
remember that partial assignment has to
has to falsify a particular clause the
particular clause that's labeling that
that leaf okay so the proof that we
showed before
was where we said c4 even though the
paths
some of the past all the paths to that
vertex didn't falsify c4
uh that wouldn't be allowed anymore okay
so again this is like a dag this is a
you should think of this as a dag like
uh branching program for solving a total
search problem with the extra condition
that it's not just solving it it's sort
of witnessing the the solution
at every leaf okay and with this
with this top-down view of resolution we
can proceed to prove resolution bounds
this is not how they were originally
proven
but it's it's uh it's kind of the nicest
way now that we think about it we can
think about resolution for
lower bounds as proceeding by first
showing
that for a random f any resolution dag
requires
linear memory or linear width meaning
that there has to be
regardless of how big the dag is there
has to be some vertex where we remember
a partial assignment
of linear size okay and that sort of
corresponds to the
to in the tree resolution pace showing
that any tree
uh decision tree for solving the search
problem has to have a long pass
so this is the the this is the analog of
that in the dag case we want to show
that any
resolution dag for solving search
problem somewhere along the line you
have to remember a whole lot
about about the partial assignment and
then we use this really lovely
uh relationship by ben sassoon victor
that that
ben's assumed riggerson that allows us
to immediately
go from lower bounds on width or memory
to lower bounds on size so their theorem
states that
any small size resolution dag implies
a width uh you know so the resolution
dag has a size
s polynomial then there is another
resolution dag of width
square root of n log s so roughly square
root of n
poly log n and so that together gives us
our contradiction and the way we prove
the width bound
part one that's proven um again
by by designing an adversary strategy
similar to what
i alluded to for the tree case and the
whole
what what you're leveraging and the
strategy is the expansion of the graph
meaning that it's
you cannot locally there's always a a
strategy
where until you go for linearly
unless you're remembering a linear
amount of stuff there's it's not going
to be possible to kind of
uh know where the contradiction is
without looking globally at a lot of
clauses
okay
okay so i'll skip so this this sort of
uh this lower bound
lets us know or basically certifies
these this experimental results
that really is the case that resolution
based algorithms
for random cnfs uh you know can't refute
random cns even way above the threshold
and i wanted to mention one really one
result that i think is really cool by
uh
building on the lower bound techniques
for random formulas
they showed something super interesting
where they studied
uh a class of
algorithms for solving random instances
of set
uh that are based on resolution and but
they were looking at sad algorithms in
the satisfiable
in the sat regime so random three cnn
formulas
that are satisfiable so where you pick
uh you know say
3m or 3.5 n clauses
so the formula is almost certainly
satisfiable and what they were able to
show
using very similar techniques but really
great idea
is that when you're running one of these
uh heuristics that are based on
resolution
on the sat random set formula again by
leveraging the
expansion properties of the formula very
likely it's going to be the case that
that
even though the formula is satisfiable
before you find that
that good path which is in purple here
you're going to stumble upon a sub
problem
which is the blue thing on the left so
you'll you'll have fixed some variables
you know and you'll fix some partial
assignment
that'll leave you with a residual
formula where you plug in that
restriction
and that residual formula will be a mix
of clauses of size 2 and 3 because
you'll have set some variables
that residual formula under this
restriction will with very high
probability be
unsat and very hard to prove so even
though
the formula is satisfiable which is the
purple
uh mick jagger path
uh before you get to that you're very
likely to encounter
a mixed two to three a mixed formula
which is a residual formula
that's unset and that's hard to prove so
you're going to waste exponential amount
of time
refuting that before you move on to the
nice purple line
any questions okay so cutting plans i
won't have time to say too much
but that's okay i'm going to tell you
what cutting planes is state the result
and a little bit how to proof
uh a little bit how the proof goes um
so cutting planes is a stronger proof
system than resolution lines are linear
inequalities
um so each line looks like you know the
sum of
some constants a i x i is greater than
equal to b and those are
called the ai's and the b's are the
weights
and the rules standard rules for cutting
planes is that you can
take two previously derived inequalities
and you can add them up
you can multiply previously derived
inequality by an integer and then you
can the division rule you can
as long as you have some integer c that
divides
all of the weights on the left side you
can divide through by
c rounding up on the right okay so this
is the important rule
the third one that kind of allows you to
to get remove
some non-integral points
um so cutting planes uh
have a have a a a fairly long history
in terms of proving lower bounds the
original methods for proving lower
bounds for cutting planes
uh use the reduction to
so first of all we use we look at very
special types of formulas called
interpolant formulas
so they're formed very special formulas
of a particular type that allows us to
convert a proof of a refutation of a
formula of that type
in cutting planes allows us to show that
if you had a small refutation
in cutting planes of this type then you
could kind of extract from the
reputation
a monotone circuit that solves a
corresponding
monotone problem and in this case uh
there's a
we use a formula that's based on the
clique so formula it states that a graph
has a clique
of size k and k minus one co clique
which is unset and then if you have a
small cutting planes proof
uh it turns out that then you can
extract from the proof a small monotone
circuit
that can distinguish graphs that contain
cliques from
grafts that contain k minus one cochleas
and so then basically we're reducing the
cutting plane's lower bound to a
monotone circuit bound
and that argument was generalized
recently in a really nice paper
um that i won't say too much more about
but what is the problem for us so if we
want to prove cutting planes bound for
random formulas
we random forms are not of this
particular nice
form that we were able to exploit in
order to prove the lower bounds
that i mentioned briefly on the previous
page but it turns out that we can still
use the ideas behind that proof
indirectly
because the random formulas kind of have
so much uh
so many nice properties in there and
they're so much embedded in them
uh that that when you look under the
hood at the proof you can kind of use
the same properties
but more directly so with this theorem
was proven by
myself noah fleming dennis pankertoff
and robert robert independently by
paul who russian and pavel pudluck again
we showed that random
login cnfs above the threshold require
exponential size cutting planes proofs
yeah so i'll just tell you a couple
couple of words about
how the proof goes um so we're going to
do the same thing we did before we want
to come up with a top-down view of a
cutting plane's proof
and the main thing that that we want
the main point is that we want to still
study the search problem
but now because the lines are more
powerful we want to study
uh the search problem in it instead of
the search studying the search problem
in like a
decision tree model or a dag version of
a decision tree model model we want to
study the search problem in a
communication
model and that'll that'll be the analog
of
you know we'll we'll be able to under
think about cutting planes proofs of
random formulas or of any formula
as sort of um solving the search problem
via a communication
particular type of communication
protocol so what do we do well we have a
random formula f
this is an example of one because it's
maybe it's not so random but anyways it
has a bunch of clauses in it think of it
as random this is this uh you know cause
this year of
size six but we're actually gonna think
of the clause that we're going to
partition all the variables into
two halves and the blue ones and the red
ones and we'll
call them x and y and uh for now i'm
just going to assume that
the clauses of the random formula are
actually roughly balanced so every
clause has
like close to three blue variables and
close to three red variables
and that has to be fixed up and that
takes more work but this is still a
random formula
it's just a slightly different model
where you think you could think of it as
picking a one
one random formula uh random three cnn
formula with the blue variables
and then a separate one with the green
variables and then just uh put
clause ones together plus twos together
and so on
okay so this is the formula again the
only difference is that i've partitioned
the variables into two groups and for
today i'm making this assumption that
all the clauses are balanced
it's the same search problem given an
assignment to the variables find a
violated clause
but now we want to solve the search
problem by a pro communication protocol
where one player alice gets the blue
gets the
assignment to the blue variables so
we'll call that alpha
and another player bob gets an
assignment beta to the red variables
and they want to send bits back and
forth now to
to agree on an answer which is a clause
that's falsified by f
so that's the communication model
and again we if we want a tree like
bound for cutting planes
then we can just study the normal
communication
complexity of solving the search problem
but if we want
dag like cutting planes bounds then we
have to generalize
the communication model to the dag-like
version and that was done by raspberry
off it's similar to what i said before
so that's the first step but that was
already done
um and yeah this takes some more work to
do this for
the case of for case of cutting planes
of big weights
um but this is just a very high level
right now
so so the first thing we do is this
general step of
converting cutting planes refutations
into showing that a cutting plane's
reputation of small size
uh gives our eyes to a dag-like
communication protocol for solving the
search problem
communication protocol and then the
second step is to sort of
realize that the dag-like communication
complexity of the search problem
you can kind of think of it in a
different way which is
you can think of it as the as actually
um
instead of solving the search problem
you can think of it as being yes and no
instances
of a boolean monotone bullying function
where alice gets
a a yes instance of a monotone function
bob gets a no instance and they're
trying to communicate back and forth
to to find a variable where alice's
value is one and bob's is zero so that's
the car rig justin communication problem
associated with the monotone function
and it turns out that
uh when you study the dag that the
dag-like communication flexi the search
problem
is or pretty much is if you think about
it the right way
uh the same as a dag-like communication
complexity
of the monotone karshmir wigderson
um game associated with a monotone
function that's associated with f
we'll call that csp sub f and then then
it all basically boils down to
proving monotone circuit lower bounds
for this monotone function the csp sub f
so at the end of the day we're yeah
we're extracting from a small cutting
plane's refutation
a monotone circuit for solving this
problem very much like the interpolation
method did but we're
kind of doing it in a less direct way so
the end of the day we're trying to prove
a monotone circuit
bound for csp and uh just to say a word
about that
um so tony i i was i'm out of time
yeah no i wonder if you want to like i
mean
we are a minute out of time but if you
want to leave room for questions
yes sure yeah i'll skip that um
yeah so i can just end here i just
wanted to say that i think there's a
whole lot still to do here
um prove cutting get getting rid of
getting this lower bound hold for k
being a constant is a really good
problem
um like i said earlier we really need
some conditional bounds for fragrance
systems
and one a third one that maybe people
don't think as much about is this whole
area in logic
or called reverse mathematics where
instead of seeing what you
can prove from a theory you instead take
a statement that you care about and you
see
if you added that to to a theory or if
you added that to a proof system
then then what would the power of it be
so it's sort of like trying to
understand
how the relative strength of these
formulas in particular like if
how how how strong or random unset form
is if you added
them kind of as axioms to to a weaker
system
like resolution or ac zero figure could
you then
simulate a stronger system like fraga is
there
yeah is there some sense in which we can
at least show that random onset formulas
are
are ubiquitous um
yeah that's about all right if anybody
wants questions and
i can i just want to say thank you for a
fantastic talk in such a
uh old encompassing and so clear so i
just wanted to say
any questions quick questions
raise your hand or just unmute yourself
i think we'll digest it i have a
question
albert here so you're mentioning here
the circuit lower bound formulas and you
did
state them earlier and in fact you did
state the recent result that there's uh
if fake a hypothesis is true then this
the
the minimum circuit size problem is hard
on average
and isn't that exactly a reduction from
random set to certain lower bound
formulas
um sorry could you say the middle you
cut out in
your middle sentence so i heard you
sorry
yeah so you stated a recent result that
says that
the fake a hypothesis implies that the
minimum circuit size problem is hard on
average
i see what you're saying yeah so i'm not
sure uh
yeah i think you're right but i'm not
positive because i don't know how that
result goes exactly
are you are you familiar with it no no
i wanted to know what you know about it
yeah um
maybe we could talk offline i don't know
enough okay
no problem
okay so yeah but that is the kind of
result i was yeah
that i think is really interesting
so i think at this point uh people
should write to tony separately and to
ask her questions and i want to thank
you again for
really a wonderful talk so thanks again
thanks everybody thank you tony
bye bye see ya